if you want to become the best most
functional
most performant version of yourself
train your ambidexterity
ambidexterity or cross dominance is the
ability to move both limbs with equal
control
strength and precision this is a
spectrum with people being more or less
ambidextrous
in any number of activities it is also
something that can be trained
however very few people actively train
for ambidexterity
this i feel is a big mistake let me make
a case for it
i am far from the first guy to recommend
training ambidexterity
in the early 20th century this was the
mission statement of the ambidextrous
culture society
established by john jackson his goal was
to promote
two-brainedness and wrote that each hand
shall be absolutely independent of the
other
in the production of any kind of work
whatever if required
one hand shall be writing an original
letter and the other shall be playing
the piano
lofty ames indeed becoming ambidextrous
has a vast number of immediate tangible
benefits
a fighter for example can benefit from
being able to throw equally powerful
blows from either arm or leg
an artist benefits from being able to
reach different angles without smudging
paint where they've already been
a bodybuilder can develop greater
muscular symmetry a footballer can kick
from either leg a tracer can jump from
either
a dancer can move with greater full body
control
in fact the lefty advantage as it's
known is thought to explain the
disproportionate number
of high-performing left-handed players
in many sports
it has even been suggested that the very
reason we still have lefties
is that they enjoy a competitive
advantage in combat this is the
fighting hypothesis it's also backed up
by the fact that animal species that
rely on cooperation
tend to trend more to a single side even
your physical attractiveness may be
linked to your handedness
it has been suggested that the side we
consider to be our good side
is normally our dominant side that's
because we have greater control over the
facial muscles on that side
symmetry is coincidentally a trait that
we universally find attractive
this is just scratching the surface of
how and why ambidexterity is so valuable
because the other thing to remember is
that muscles are not just used for force
production
muscles are also sensory organs that
provide information about our bodies
and the world around us ambidexterity as
far as it would mean increasing
dexterity on the non-dominant side
should also improve our ability to feel
movement in those areas
this gives us a more detailed picture of
our bodies in space
and that theoretically could improve
balance and graceful movement across the
board
there are several studies that show
left-handedness and ambidexterity are
linked with improved spatial ability
other studies interestingly find that
this effect is strongest in men
which may have something to do with
brain lateralization and we'll come to
that more in a moment
any bodybuilder knows the importance of
muscle symmetry this has immediate
aesthetic benefits
but the effect on performance and health
are perhaps even more important
imagine that you are running a 10k and
one leg is slightly stronger and more
coordinated than the other
the result could be that when you push
off the weaker leg you actually travel a
few centimeters less than the other side
that might sound like not a lot but now
consider how that adds up over the
course of all those steps
and consider how that can impact on your
overall time and effort
studies also suggest that learning a
skill with one hand can actually provide
benefit to
the other hand this works both ways
meaning that if you practice a skill
with your non-dominant hand
you'll actually improve with your
dominant hand even if you'd hit a kind
of plateau
in all likelihood the added focus and
attention that you're giving to the
movement pattern when learning on that
side is what helps you to further refine
the movement on
both sides but perhaps the real
advantage of ambidexterity training
could come from the very process of
learning a new challenging motor skill
itself
i've talked at length about the
importance of motor learning to keep the
brain flexible and powerful
after all the sheer amount of
information processing that occurs
during movement exceeds anything
you might accomplish sitting in front of
a book this very process of attending to
information and learning
is what encourages plasticity it changes
the brain to keep it learning
this could also potentially strengthen
the motor cortex at large
this strategy is employed by the
aerosmith school where learning
challenge students use tracing exercises
to see widespread improvements in their
language production
both written and spoken could similar
training with the non-dominant hand
improve verbal fluency for everyone
motor neuroscientist professor amy
bastian says
the more variety of things you do in the
fine motor domain the more variety of
hand movements you make
will improve your dexterity dr andrew
huberman's amazing podcasts
illustrate the benefit of learning new
complex sensory rich movements
for unlocking the brain's plasticity he
suggests inversions such as handstands
is a particularly good option for those
unfamiliar with them
learning fine control with a
non-dominant hand may be an alternative
option
we should note that many people believe
ambidexterity comes with heightened
creativity and problem solving
this comes partly from the anecdotal
evidence that famously ambidextrous
individuals such as da vinci einstein
ben franklin and tesla
were all known for their genius levels
of creativity the ambidexterity of these
individuals
has been called into question at times
though a recent study suggests that da
vinci really was in fact ambidextrous
moreover this is a very small sample
size and i could point to many more
notable individuals who are not
cross-dominant some suggest that
ambidexterity may correlate with lower
brain
lateralization that is to say that the
brain's structures are less neatly
organized on either side of the brain
and are more dispersed across both
hemispheres resulting in brains that are
more symmetrical among the ambidextrous
population
this may also result in a thicker corpus
callosum the bundle of nerves that
bridges the hemispheres
posthumous autopsies of einstein's brain
revealed that he did in fact possess a
thicker than average corpus callosum
and we know that women on the whole have
a naturally less symmetrical brain
which makes sense of that study we
looked at earlier with more information
traveling more freely around the brain
it is possible that there's a greater
potential for novel connections to form
between ideas
left-handers who make up approximately
ten percent of the population
as opposed to the one percent of truly
ambidextrous individuals
also tend to have less brain
lateralization this is due to the
increased need for ambidexterity
in a right-hand world a change in
lateralization
could also result in other cognitive
differences one study found that those
with left-handed relatives
deemed to be weak-handed and therefore
more ambidextrous
actually had better episodic memories
memories for events
those same individuals also demonstrated
poorer semantic memory the study author
suggests that this difference stems from
the fact that episodic memories are
coded across multiple brain areas
where semantic memories require just one
hemisphere
being able to pull information from
across the brain is useful for episodic
recall
but the crosstalk may result in unwanted
interference when it comes to semantic
information
hampering speed and accuracy those with
sinistrality
in their dna may find their thoughts
take the scenic route so to speak
it is true that there's a greater
incidence of various cognitive
disturbances in ambidextrous individuals
a number of studies link ambidexterity
to poorer iq scores
adhd schizophrenia and more
interestingly both adhd and
schizophrenia
are linked with creativity whereas iq
tests benefit from rapid processing of
information
however this correlation is unlikely to
be causative
that is to say that in some cases
ambidexterity is a symptom of
development issues
and not the reverse there is evidence
for this as we see in a review of the
literature conducted by johanna
barbara satella systematic
investigations of the second group of
subjects
always revealed perinatal cerebral
disturbances
this paper discusses the thesis the
insufficient oxygen supply to the brain
in the perinatal period of life
mainly affects the function of the
dominant cerebral hemisphere that is
responsible
for the congenital handedness
even if increased brain symmetry results
in a less organized brain it is highly
unlikely that training for ambidexterity
later in life would result in the
migration of entire brain functions
we would not likely see the brain become
significantly more symmetrical
as we simply lack that kind of
plasticity in adulthood that said we
might be able to thicken the corpus
callosum
in order to improve communication
between hemispheres
and we might see improvements in the
motor cortex and cerebellum
many people could benefit from being a
little more creative
note that the link between weak
handedness and a thicker corpus callosum
is far from proven however
so how do you train this most people
looking to improve their ambidexterity
will be writing with a non-dominant hand
other drills include tooth brushing with
the left hand swapping cutlery over etc
this is a great starting point and can
help to develop fine motor control
that will almost certainly transfer to
other tasks to some extent
in fact an interesting demonstration of
this comes from young children
our health visitor told us that our
daughter emmy would be able to brush her
own teeth
only once she'd started writing at
school it's the process of writing you
see
that develops the coordination and
control necessary to create those small
circles with the brush
we've already seen that the aerosmith
school uses similar strategies to help
improve verbal fluency
of their pupils other inherently
ambidextrous practices such as learning
to play the piano
can also have similar effects musicians
that use both hands have been shown to
have thicker corpus callosums
although this is only true for male
musicians rock climbing too may also
offer some benefits
for boosting creativity and more all
these options should prove
highly effective but transfer across
all skills is not a given one study
found that our non-dominant hands are
actually superior when it comes to
holding things steady
this makes a lot of sense given that we
so often hold something in one hand
and manipulate it with the other the
image of a bow and arrow comes to mind
this also suggests that through practice
we've improved different types of skill
on each hand this suggests that we need
a broader approach
many of us are so lacking in nambi
dexterity that any additional training
will benefit us
to an extent but just as practicing
cursive with your right hand is only
going to improve your right hook to a
certain degree
so too can we get more benefit with
specific training on the left side
in other words if you want to get better
at punching with your left hand you
should practice
punching with your left hand keep in
mind that this is a whole body movement
that involves coordination of the
shoulders fists hips and more
right now you probably lack the
necessary motor mats to engage all those
motor units
in the right sequence and with the same
explosiveness you enjoy on your dominant
side
you likewise also probably struggle to
achieve the reciprocal inhibition
that ensures antagonistic muscles will
relax during the movement
this is as much about strength as it is
about dexterity
the ability to recruit larger motor
units as needed
likewise functional movement patterns
like cable chops cable punch-outs and
one-handed push-ups
can all strengthen these areas similarly
unilateral movements that involve
jumping from one leg or lifting on one
side embracing the core on the other
have huge benefit eithering unilateral
exercises will also encourage
symmetrical muscle development
and strength finally though we should
also practice movements that train both
sides simultaneously
i've spoken recently about movements
like crawls and their contralateral
nature
and how that challenges us to exert
strength and control between hemispheres
this cross-lateral movement helps us to
develop the corpus callosum
in infancy and it can be used just the
same way in adulthood
in fact any complex movement that
requires communication between the two
sides of the body
may offer these benefits other options
include juggling the aforementioned rock
climbing
tai chi yoga other certain types of
martial arts etc
we can also use more complex movements
in strength training creating hybrid
movements that require strength
to be exerted on different vectors
simultaneously
this could not only develop strength and
control but also spatial awareness
and perhaps even creativity
so i hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you did then
please leave a like and share around
that helps me out
immensely subscribe if you want more
like this and hit the notification
button
if you want to be notified of new
uploads let me know what you think in
the comments down below
i think ambidexterity training has the
potential to unlock unknown depths of
athletic performance
and to affect our brains in really
interesting ways is this something
you've experimented with
or will you do now if you want to learn
more about training your body in
all kinds of different ways all at once
to become as functional as possible then
check out my ebook and training program
super functional training i'll leave a
link to that in the description down
below
and there's a discount on right now
whilst we're all in lockdown
alternatively you can check out my print
book functional training and beyond
which will take you on a journey through
the history of functional training and
all the different
forms of training you can apply to
create a more well-rounded program
yourself
either way thanks so much for watching
this one guys thank you for all your
support
and i'll see you next time bye
for now